notbremse in sachsen das bundesland mit
den meisten neuinfektionen schließt ab
montag schulen kindergärten und fast
alle geschäfte premiere in
großbritannien die 90 jährige margaret
kennen bekommt die erste impfdosis gegen
korona und manche fragen auf was warten
die eu-länder rückzieher in magdeburg um
so eine koalition zu retten setzt
sachsen anhalts ministerpräsident die
entscheidende abstimmung über den
rundfunkbeitrag im landtag aus
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und nimmt in allen an
diesem dienstag zum nachrichtenüberblick
und schon mal vorab danke für ihr
interesse
katja hat nachher den sport hallo guten
hand es ist ein tag an dem wir wieder
eingehend über die korona lage in
deutschland berichten müssen weil sie
nach wie vor sorgen macht es wird immer
wahrscheinlicher dass die maßnahmen um
das virus einzudämmen noch mal
verschärft werden
im extremfall bis hin zu einem harten
lockdown in sachsen gelten schon ab
montag strenge regeln schulen und
kindergärten schließen nur noch
lebensnotwendige geschäfte dürfen öffnen
in sachsen liegen einige der am
stärksten von corona betroffenen
deutschen regionen
die regeln sollen bis zum 10 januar
gelten wir beginnen unsere
berichterstattung heute abend mit
cornelia schiemenz in dresden lange hat
sachsens ministerpräsident noch gehofft
dass die zahlen wieder nach unten gehen
dass die menschen eigenverantwortlich
und vernünftig sind
heute nun die notbremse ab montag geht
der ganze freistaat in den kompletten
shutdown
damit kehrt die ruhe um weihnachten und
den jahreswechsel im freistaat sachsen
in diesem jahr etwas früher ein als
sonst
wir haben uns vorgenommen dass diese
maßnahmen bis zum 10
januar gelten sollen ein auf der einen
seite überschaubarer zeitraum und
trotzdem eine herausforderung vier
wochen stille keine schule keine kita
kein shopping die masten pflicht überall
im öffentlichen raum menschen sollen zu
hause bleiben weil sachsens kliniken am
limit sind im helios-klinikum freital
liegen heute mehr als 70 cupid patienten
so viele wie noch nie
es ist notwendig diesen lockdown einfach
zu machen weil wir können einfach auf
dauer hier im landkreis aber auch im
umfeld in sachsen mit diesem fall zahlen
im gesundheitssystem einfach nicht
weiter umgehen bei einer zufalls
befragung heute in freital zustimmung
zum shutdown wieder machen
als wenn wir zu lange damit warten wir
wollen nicht sterben und krank sind
das ist doch nicht nur gesund bleiben
ich habe eltern mit 90 zu hause
die sollen wenn es geht weihnachten
alleine sitzen es hätte ja was passieren
sollen weihnachten im shutdown
da tröstet auch die prächtige tanne auf
dem dresdner altmarkt nicht mehr
ja und so sieht die lage in ganz
deutschland aufgrund der gemeldeten
positiven testergebnisse aus innerhalb
von 24 stunden meldet das
robert-koch-institut 14.000 54
neuinfektionen
das sind 400 50 mehr als vor einer woche
es gab durch oder in verbindung mit dem
virus 423 todesfälle
was heißt das für ganz deutschland die
nationale akademie der wissenschaften
leopoldina empfiehlt das öffentliche
leben bundesweit bereits ab kommender
woche bis mindestens zehnter januar
herunterzufahren david geppert ein land
im teil shutdown kontakte reduziert
gastronomie geschlossen doch noch sind
die läden auf büros und schulen
zumindest die meisten
das muss sich ändern rasch fordern heute
führende wissenschaftler der leopoldina
akademie die die bundesregierung berät
wir fordern dass wir schon am 14
dezember beginnen die sozialen kontakte
zu reduzieren dort wo es geht das heißt
schüler beispielsweise dürfen auch schon
zu hause bleiben und ab dem 24
dezember dann ein harter lockdown
schließung der geschäfte die wir nicht
für den täglichen gebrauch haben es sind
nur empfehlungen doch immer mehr
regierenden eben diese zumindest
teilweise auf bayern etwa setzt sich
dafür ein geschäfte von weihnachten bis
10 januar zu schließen hessen verkündet
nächtliche ausgangssperren in besonderen
corona hot spots ab wochenende und den
thüringen etwa fallen die lockerungen zu
weihnachten aus die instituts werte
seien zu hoch deswegen ist es so dass
wir tatsächlich die ganzen
einschränkungen die wir im november auf
den weg gebracht haben nicht in
irgendeiner form lockern können sondern
nach scharf
zwischen der versprochene effekt des
wellenbrecher lockt downs versandet
längst fordert auch die bundesregierung
verschärfte maßnahmen immer mehr länder
schwenken 1
wir reiten auf der rasierklinge und
deswegen bin ich der meinung es braucht
einen harten lockdown der
deutschlandweit gilt wir haben es mit
einer heftigen zweiten welle zu tun und
wir werden sicherlich deutschlandweit
über weitere maßnahmen reden müssen
viel wird gefordert viel verschärft aber
noch wenig abgestimmt die adventszeit im
corona winter 2020 noch mal nachgefragt
live in berlin teo genannt ist denn
absehbar wann es jetzt für ganz
deutschland klarheit gibt was denn
gelten soll
also in dieser woche wohl eher nicht
mehr nicht zuletzt weil die kanzlerin
als eu ratspräsidentin ja so kleine
andere verpflichtungen hat wie ein eu
gipfel am donnerstag und freitag zur
krone laufen hier aktuell heftige
gespräche in den politischen kulissen
und das meinungsspektrum reicht von
zusätzlichen harten maßnahmen bis zu in
anführungsstrichen nur die angekündigten
weihnachts lockerungen wieder zu
streichen
verschärft wird in jedem fall die frage
ist wie weit und wie einheitlich theo
jetzt haben wir seit 20 mb mit einem
teil shutdown versuchte in deutschland
der hat keine durchgreifende
verbesserung gebracht ist das was wir
heute aus der politik hören auch ein
eingeständnis dass da wertvolle zeit
vertan wurde
ich glaube genau so muss man es wohl
bewerten und wenn ein ministerpräsident
entschuldigen sagt wir alle hätten das
virus unterschätzt dann stimmt das eben
nicht für alle
nicht zuletzt das kanzleramt ihr wollte
seit anfang der krise eine härtere linie
einzelne länder chefs haben aber
natürlich aus nachvollziehbaren
wirtschaftlichen und auch
gesellschaftlichen gründen und weil sie
lange zeit weniger von infektionen
betroffen waren geglaubt weniger wäre
gut genug war es aber ganz
offensichtlich nicht und die
konsequenzen dessen dürften dann unsere
kommenden wochen prägen
theo koll live in berlin hat sich ein
dank eine 90 jährige schreibt heute
corona geschichte in großbritannien dort
haben massen impfungen begonnen die
briten preschen damit vor in europa der
impfstoff des deutschen unternehmens
biontech und seines partners pfizer hat
in großbritannien einen notfall
zulassung bekommen
61.000 menschen sind in großbritannien
an oder mit dem corona virus gestorben
so viele wie sonst nirgendwo in europa
andreas stamm berichtet tief durchatmen
ein historischer moment mit der
90-jährigen margret thiem beginnt das
größte im programm in der britischen
geschichte
sie habe keine bedenken obwohl der erste
einsatz des impfstoffs nur durch eine
notfall zulassung möglich ist
wenn ich das kann dann doch jeder
lasst euch kämpfen es kostet nichts und
ist das beste was je passiert ist
priorität genießen über 80 jähriger
mitarbeiter im gesundheits und
pflegebereich die größte hürde nur unter
minus 70 grad hält der stoff länger
bislang verhindert unter anderem das
geplante impfungen direkt in
pflegeheimen großbritannien hat
impfstoff für 400.000 menschen erhalten
für jeweils zwei dosen im abstand von
drei wochen eine woche danach soll der
volle schutz bestehen ein schutzschild
auch für den premier besuchten einem der
rund 50 im krankenhäuser im land nach
harter kritik an johnsons kurs in der
pandemie nach 62.000 toten spricht er
vom wendepunkt im kampf gegen korona und
mahnte wir dürfen trotzdem nicht
unachtsam werden das ist meine botschaft
aber es ist fantastisch dass ein
impfstoff da ist eine gewaltige aufbau
spritze in den arm der gesamten nation 4
millionen dosen des biotech kaiser
impfstoff sollen bis ende des jahres
geliefert werden andere vakzine stehen
vor der zulassung licht am ende des
tunnels und hoffnung für mark keenan
dass sie nach einem jahr voller
einsamkeit bald wieder freunde und
familie in die arme schließen kann
was für ein bild die us
arzneimittelbehörde hat dem corona
impfstoff von biotech und pfizer heute
bescheinigt dass er sehr wirksam sei ob
der impfstoff in den usa angewendet
werden darf wird sie vermutlich in den
kommenden tagen entscheiden
und was ist mit uns den aktuellen stand
hat anselm stern bei den briten ging es
extrem schnell
der grund das verfahren nationalen
notfall zulassung heißt der impfstoff
wird in großbritannien sofort
freigegeben
auch wenn weniger daten über den
wirkstoff verfügbar sind als
normalerweise üblich
das hätte deutschland auch machen können
die bundesregierung aber setzt auf eine
eu weite lösung da analysiert die
europäische arzneimittelagentur die
impfstoffe dauert etwa vier wochen am
ende des verfahrens steht dann eine
bedingte zulassung für die gesamte eu
dabei werden die angaben der hersteller
überprüft etwa zu wirksamkeit und
sicherheit
hier gibt es eine vertiefte bewertung
durch die expertinnen und experten des
paul ehrlich instituts und der anderen
national arzneimittelbehörden in den
eu-mitgliedstaaten das ist sehr guter
weg ein weg der konsequenzen hat bei der
bedingten zulassung in der eu haften vor
allem die hersteller wenn es probleme
mit dem impfstoff gibt bei der
britischen notfall zulassung haftet dann
vor allem der britische staat
schnelligkeit sei also nicht nur ein
vorteil
wichtig es gar nicht so sehr für uns er
kommt zuerst an sondern wichtig ist dass
jetzt anfang des jahres mehrere
impfstoff produkte zu im flug in europa
doch in deutschland verfügbar sein
werden heißt es kann anfang des jahres
losgehen genug impfstoff genug geimpfte
menschen für ein ende der krise das wird
noch deutlich länger dauern
krone hat viele folgen auch finanzielle
der bundestag hat den weg frei gemacht
für die zweithöchste neuverschuldung in
der geschichte dieses landes fast eine
halbe billion euro ausgaben sind für
nächstes jahr geplant zum vergleich in
den letzten jahren lagen die ausgaben
immer zwischen 300 und 350 milliarden in
diesem jahr dann in der pandemie sind
sie explodiert und im kommenden jahr
sollen es dann fast 180 mio
euro neue schulden werden das parlament
hat dafür die schuldenbremse wieder
außer kraft gesetzt mehr von thomas
reich hat der finanzminister an diesem
tag einen dicken stapel papiere
mitgebracht es geht schließlich um ein
corona haushalt mit rekordausgaben und
rekordschulden die die opposition heftig
kritisiert man kein wertschöpfung nicht
durch geldschöpfung ersetzen und dennoch
versucht die regierung nun genau das
auch die fdp kritisiert die höhe der
schulden und dass milliarden an corona
hilfen viele unternehmen noch immer
nicht erreicht hätten viele
familienbetriebe fühlen sich wie damals
in der ddr im schaufenster ist die große
auflage in milliarden höhe von olaf
scholz bereitgestellt und man betritt
den laden und dann heißt es liefert seit
zwei jahren meine damen und herren der
finanzminister dagegen erklärt die
eigene haushaltspolitik zum goldstandard
rekordschulden seien notwendig ich
glaube es ist so dass wir vor der krise
eine solide haushaltspolitik gemacht
haben und dass wir auch jetzt eine
solide haushaltspolitik machen weil wir
viel geld einsetzen aber wohlüberlegt
und für einen guten zweck nämlich wie
wir durch die krise kommen herr 96 der
bundestag die schuldenbremse außer kraft
linke und grüne fordern dass sie auch
danach nicht einfach mit der eingesetzt
wird wenn man wirklich zur
schuldenbremse zurückkehren will
da ist das eine völlig verrückte idee da
bremst man die wirtschaft von 100 auf
null runter und die schuldenbremse die
hat doch nicht die schulden gebremst
dann die bremst die investition man muss
dafür sorgen dass kommt nach corinna
nicht der rotstift angesetzt wird das
wäre gift für die wirtschaftliche
erholung dass wir auch gift für den
sozialen zusammenhalt in unserer
gesellschaft auch scholz wäre deshalb
für höhere abgaben für top verdiener der
streit darüber wer die rechnung nach der
pandemie bezahlen soll hat gerade erst
begonnen
unser nächstes thema in sachsen anhalt
hat die koalitionsregierung ihren streit
um den rundfunkbeitrag beigelegt indem
sie gar nicht darüber entscheidet
ministerpräsident reiner haseloff von
der cdu sowie spd und grüne haben den
gesetzentwurf von der tagesordnung des
landtags gestrichen damit ist auf der
einen seite zwar ihre kriselnde
koalition gerettet auf der anderen ist
aber die einigung aller übrigen
bundesländer zur finanzierung des
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks erst
mal blockiert
hagen nikolaus berichtet nach wochen des
koalitionsstreits zieht
ministerpräsident haseloff die reißleine
weil sich cdu spd und grüne über den
medien staatsvertrag nicht einigen
können nimmt asel auf seinen
gesetzentwurf vor der abstimmung im
landtag zurück damit ist sozusagen erst
eine entscheidung gefällt worden dass es
zu keinem ratifizierungsverfahren im
landtag kommen kann weil dieses
verfahren aussichtslos ist für ein nein
zum staatsvertrag wie es die cdu wollte
hätte sie auch stimmen der afg gebraucht
für spd und grüne
grund mit dem aus der koalition zu
drohen und obwohl beide den medien
staatsvertrag befürworten
tragen sie nun haseloffs vorgehen mit
damit ist zumindest gelungen dass es
keine gemeinsame abstimmung über einen
realpolitischen fakt einer produktions
fraktion und der fdp fraktion im landtag
geben kann
wir haben als grüne hier viereinhalb
jahre sehr viel dafür getan dass das
bollwerk gegen recht zählt wenn wir
jetzt hier aufgeben wäre das alles
umsonst gewesen dass aus der schwarz rot
grünen regierung ist damit verhindert
der medien staatsvertrag von
sachsen-anhalt gestoppt die opposition
im landtag übt daran kritik wenn auch
aus unterschiedlicher motivation
es ist natürlich wieder so wie es auch
bei den crooner maßnahmen ist dass ein
parlament hier außen vor gelassen wird
das vorher eine entscheidung gesucht
wird bevor ihren parlament abstimmt und
das halten wir für nicht so besonders
gut kenia war keine brandmauer gegen
rechts und zeigt jetzt sehr deutlich
wohin diese cdu-geführte landesregierung
driftet man hat eins zu eins nicht nur
beim öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk
hf die positionen übernommen man hat
einen staatsvertrag geschreddert der
koalitionsstreit in sachsen anhalt ist
vom tisch das thema medien staatsvertrag
in deutschland noch nicht so
entwicklungen magdeburg gibt es
außerhalb von sachsen anhalt viele
kritische stimmen schließlich haben die
meisten landtage der beitragserhöhung
schon zugestimmt und neu verhandeln
wollen die ministerpräsidenten darüber
nicht mehr
die öffentlich rechtlichen sender gehen
jetzt vors bundesverfassungsgericht mehr
dazu von bobby cherry keine abstimmung
in magdeburg bedeutet vorerst keine
beitragserhöhung für zdf ard
deutschlandradio und die medienanstalten
dabei hatten die meisten
länderparlamente schon zugestimmt
von einem schwarzen tag für die deutsche
medien und demokratie geschichte spricht
die rheinland pfälzische
ministerpräsident und vorsitzende der
rundfunkkommission der länder
der öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk ist
eine wichtige säule unserer demokratie
und er hat den anspruch nach der
rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts auf eine
auskömmliche finanzierung und ist völlig
klar mit der nicht abstimmung in sachsen
anhalt wird der staatsvertrag nicht in
kraft treten können und damit wird es
nicht zu einer beitragserhöhung kommen
im februar hatte die unabhängige
kommission kef empfohlen den
rundfunkbeitrag anzuheben zum ersten mal
seit elf jahren ab januar 2021 sollte
der monatliche betrag von 17 eur 50 auf
18 eur 36 steigen
12 eur 78 sollten an die ard gehen vier
euro 69 an das zdf knapp 90 cent an
deutschlandradio und die medienanstalten
das verfahren zur festlegung des beitrag
ist der von allen ländern beschlossen
worden um die unabhängigkeit der
öffentlich-rechtlichen anstalten
sicherzustellen insbesondere auch in
ihrer politischen berichterstattung
nun ist die beitrags- festlegung in
sachsen anhalt zu einem politischen
streitthema geworden
deshalb bleibt im zdf leider keine
andere möglichkeit als das
bundesverfassungsgericht anzurufen
die verfassungsbeschwerde wird noch in
diesem jahr eingereicht werden dann ist
die justiz am zug
ein großer tag heute für den münchner
wissenschaftler reinhard genzel in der
bayerischen staatskanzlei bekommt er den
nobelpreis für physik
der astrophysiker gentzel hat den
nachweis erbracht dass es schwarze
löcher tatsächlich gibt
eigentlich werden die auszeichnungen ja
traditionell in stockholm verliehen in
diesem jahr aber bekommen die
preisträger medaille und urkunde
pandemie bedingt an ihrem wohnort
herzlichen glückwunsch und damit der
sport und katja und im fußball da geht
es schlag auf schlag wieder eine
champions league woche heute mit
dortmund und rb leipzig und für die
leipziger ist es eine woche der
entscheidung denn will das team von
trainer julian nagelsmann sicher in die
ko runde muss heute abend gegen
manchester united unbedingt ein sieg her
ein mensch ist dass trainer ole gunnar
solksjaer der deutsche fußball nicht die
besten erinnerungen
1999 erzielte er für manunited das
siegtor im champions league finale gegen
die bayern im hinspiel
ich hab dir sein stürmer markus resch
ford drei tore bei 15 0 gegen rb ja
natürlich spielt das ergebnis spielt
nicht mehr die große rolle weil es
einfach jetzt andere voraussetzungen
sind mit musik sind wir weiter am
samstag in der liga anlage leipzig
zweimal in führung spielte am ende
unentschieden gegen manchester hilft
wahrscheinlich nur ein sieg julian
nagelsmann muss also mindestens einmal
jubeln um das achtelfinale zu erreichen
bei der handball em der frauen in
dänemark hat die deutsche mannschaft die
hauptrunde erreicht und das trotz eines
schmeichelhaften 21 zu 21 gestern abend
im letzten
gegen außenseiter polen ab übermorgen
die zahl weiter
das ziel ist und bleibt aber nicht
halbfinale
tja diese sportjahr war für alle ein
spezielles keine fußball em kein olympia
und doch kein grund auf die gala zum
jahresabschluss zu verzichten
gesucht werden die sportlerinnen
sportler und mannschaften des jahres in
kleinerem rahmen als üblich und nur mit
negativem corona test sollen sie in
baden-baden gefeiert werden die
zahlreichen glanzvollen sportlichen
leistungen des jahres 2020 die es trotz
der verschobenen olympischen
sommerspiele erstmals verliehen wird in
diesem jahr ein sonderpreis für die
sport legenden des jahrzehnts
basketball-superstar dirk nowitzki wurde
von fans und sportlern gewählt wie auch
die beachvolleyball olympiasiegerinnen
laura ludwig und kira walkenhorst sowie
die biathlon rekordweltmeisterin
magdalena neuner und die gala ghanam
zwanzigster dezember in baden-baden und
im zdf dachte ich mir
danke hat ja so wir schauen jetzt noch
auf einen erdverbundenen künstler mit
großen ambitionen der italiener dario
gambari malt erst ein bild von ludwig
van beethoven und zeigt dann darum seine
staffelei ein traktorist mit dem flug
überträgt er das bild auf einen acker in
der nähe von verona 25.000 quadratmeter
groß ein geschenk aus dem himmel gut zu
sehen zu beethovens 250 geburtstag über
nacht und morgen gibt es schnee im süden
von deutschland alle details dazu gleich
mit es denn terry heute-journal zeit
führte vor zehn wir sagen danke für
heute gerne bis morgen und in allen
einen sehr angenehmen
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter auf der
alpensüdseite schneit es weiterhin und
teilweise ergiebig und das in der
kommenden nacht und im tagesverlauf und
dieser schnee dehnt sich allmählich auch
richtung deutschland aus und im
südwesten kommt weiterer schnee hinzu
und nach norden hin geht das ganze in
regen über in der nacht schneit es im
südwesten weiter nach norden wird es
allmählich in regen übergehen und in den
nördlichen landesteilen nördlich der
mittelgebirge ist etwas regen dabei im
westen bildet sich teils dichter nebel
dort dann reifglätte bei temperaturen um
minus drei grad im süden sowieso
schneeglätte bei minus 1 bis minus 3
nach osten hin ist es frostfrei bei plus
fünf grad morgen im tagesverlauf weitere
schneefälle an den alpen und auch bis
zum 1
hier geht es aber mehr und mehr in regen
über und auch im norden gibt es regen
bis zur nordsee hoch im westen zeigt
sich auch mal die sonne bei höchsten
temperaturen von null grad an den alpen
und 7 grad im osten schauen wir auf die
nächsten tage
am donnerstag in den östlichen teilen
etwas regen und schnee im südwesten
sonnenschein - 1 bis 4 grad oder ab
freitag wird sogar etwas milder ein
schöner abend